Kerala is a place that we all love it
laughing out loud slinging on a cloud
things that rhyme with loud it's not bad
yeah that's when we were why I survived
II read that was the rock bottom moment
in that song again somewhat Kerala it's
not bad Wow
somebody fell asleep so no here's the
fight thing about these movies we're
just doing all the Care Bears movies
because it's like Ange it's just hammer
them all out um well first of all it's a
fair to say that the best is first and
they get less and less as they go yeah I
actually like I don't hate the first
Care Bears movie yeah it's not good
you're gonna get me wrong there's the
thing it's aimed at freaking
five-year-olds but what are you what are
you gonna really expect I mean it's not
like you are greeting card character
aimed at five-year-olds teaching kids to
be nice to each other I'm not expecting
high hearts here but something you said
you know when we were watching it uh you
know we said yeah it's aimed at
five-year-old yeah let's just do it cuz
it was a big part of like the moss
growing up I watched Care Bears cause a
little little kid and stuff yeah I
remember seeing it on the big screen
like so when I still see him I amelie
think of like plastic toys I don't see
fur I think of the plastic toys cuz we
had like a bunch of them um a new
plastic toys smell yes indeed no I think
I'm like a contact guy from a movies
great no it's like smelling play-doh
it's like that smell never goes away it
was like looking totes
oh hey this is why we like Care Bears
baby we just all bad we think back to
getting high this is the imagery we saw
um but now something you said is that
you say you know even though this is
obviously for little kids and stuff
there is a feeling of atmosphere too in
an environment in the first one there in
the first one in particular there
actually was effort put into it not
always cuz that's song sucked in the
open but most of the songs sucked I'm
trying to think how most of these are
all like oh songwriting was not the Care
Bears this but uh I said yeah it was one
kid Carroll at was like breaking down
and everybody was like boarding up like
it was like a hurricane was striking and
the boat is coming up and stuff I was
like
I feel the sense of size to this there
was there is a sense for aimed at
five-year-olds of epicness like this was
a step above like the cartoon show and
there was a sense of atmosphere I was
like remember watching it was turning
you during that hurricane scene I was
like this really strangely atmospheric
I'm actually kind of buying this yeah or
even like the a the target Oh at the
very end with that great creepy book and
Nicolas acting as silly as he isn't
stomach on that there's something too at
the very end I mean it's like we kind of
make love in the review but it's like as
a little kid watching that scene where
it's like just goes really quieter said
weird sad Jeff annoying it's like this
is like I don't know like I wasn't
scared as a cute but like I was drawn in
it did somehow draw me and even watching
it I was don't doubt because he had like
the judge do me then that weird fucking
Sinead O'Connor face of the bug just
like yes kill them is they were yeah I
suppose the book I think I edited that
after time but it's like yeah be you
kids there's a creepy animation going on
with like us her face is being smooth
and she's trying to protect it no but I
get a stop stop it is like it's it's its
record here in black magic for something
aimed at little kids like it's about
caring and and defeating an evil head
out of a doc gospel you know what it
kind of felt like even though it wasn't
good I felt like I was transported
somewhere else you know I felt like I
was in kind of like a different universe
I even with the villains well let's not
forget it's an origin story because we
get to find out where the Care Bear
cousin's came from yeah until the second
one when it's like origin story again
even though it's a to ask our review
generation though technically it's the
hottest image any make any sense of it's
like origin story rewritten because
birthday in separate lands and the first
Care Bears movie in the prequel they're
all together and what happened was there
some sort of Thanksgiving dinner where
they all were just like fuck you guys
so maybe that's when they learned how to
care maybe even the animation there was
still like you know I think it was one
of those things where it didn't seem
like everything was on model so they
could experiment a little bit more me
because they were kind of it felt like
they were a little newer but they they
experimented an interesting way like the
way they moved and the way they talked I
mean it was a little odd it was very
expressive and think that's why I think
about the movie I think very expressive
this was one of those in the series of
80s movies like the chipmunk adventure
where it was really high-end for what
was a lower-end movie
yeah like the lower-end movies kind of
film high-end to us at the time actually
an animation in the chipmunk movie
actually like it's it actually
legitimately good watching I mean it's
good animation but when you think about
it it's just it's the Alvin and the
chicken like you be like this is about a
crown right here yeah this isn't a
Disney movie this wouldn't been Pixar
dream like it's just like here's a
chipmunk knockoff movie and yet they
were strangely well anime and the
camera's not as good as that but it
definitely was way better than it needed
to be yeah you couldn't do that it was
wrong
anything on screen to sell tickets and
that's kind of why I like the first one
overall is I feel like no they went
above and beyond what really would have
been necessary cuz they could have done
bottom of the barrel which is what the
movies later become but again not not
good I mean I won't buy it yeah it's
good it's now like yeah I can watch that
again and really enjoy it's like no I'll
watch it be out okay this is thick can
we fast-forward this part no no I mean
again we're not the target audience like
giving people a geeky every day it's
like you watch cartoon it's like you
know it's not the target audience but
what you know it's like for the target
the target audience is fine cuz there is
stuff out there for little kids it's
like no this is awful and I'll make them
dumber and there's gonna be nothing for
them to re-watch later or enjoy or take
any substance from but you know this you
kind of can even if it's like a sense of
atmosphere and even kind of pacing
really a couple of random things I know
is the voice of penny from Inspector
Gadget is in this and it's like so
obviously from she's the first - yeah
that it kept creeping me out because it
was like I feel like I'm just watching
some weird episode of Inspector Gadget
or it's like a crossover cuz I please
yet another blonde haired girl with a
ponytail
no no she plays a brown hair in the next
one but then the blonde one that looks
just like her someone else but then the
kid that plays Nicolas is also dark hard
so they switch everything around but
they get the same voice actors doing the
exact I didn't realize that was the same
voice actors yeah I'm Nicolas endure no
no it's your everyday thing like I don't
know why but it's like I'm very thankful
because that brings us to movie 2 which
really deserves I wasn't and I wasn't
done with I want to talk about darker ok
the bathrooms are people last thing I
want to say about the first one is
something I really liked about this
movie is its moral message was be kind
to everybody and be nice in the Senedd
and it didn't fucking puss out at the
end how many fucking movies have I seen
where like kids movies in particular
where it's all like oh it's about family
and together this um friendship and yet
at the end they always just shit on the
villain yeah I'm well I get yeah they
beat him up or something or that the Toy
Story movies always come to mind where
like at the end of the villain like
always gets like you know kicked out or
the second one kind of bothered me the
most with a stinky feet yeah with stinky
peed where it's just like no this guy's
been abused all his life and yeah he's
being a jerk about but like haha we're
gonna kick your little girl's house
you're gonna live life in hell and I'm
just like wow you guys just dicks
okay what what I saw is not life in hell
it's a life hello girls how second oh
come on no his reaction was like oh my
god like that's life in hell for him
okay it's not like Toy Story 3 where I'm
almost burned alive um well yeah that's
that's another one I know I know your
time but actually was strapped to the
front of a truck I'm like that's like
torture Oh Angie yeah that was exactly
I'm like what the hell but so the thing
about this movie is the moral is be nice
and the funny thing is the Care Bears
always have this out with the Care Bear
with the Care Bear stare and like it
always was a joke to be that like it
still somehow seems like violence like
we don't know what it's doing well like
when it's all said and done it's like
fire our weapons yeah
I mean you don't know what it's doing or
how much is harming but you know it's
stopping so they're not like most feels
like massage it just contains it's
hurting yeah it's like we're gonna we're
gonna fight them with loving loving
violence um so then always bother me but
what I love about the movie is at the
very end that fucking Care Bear stare
doesn't do shit it's up to the kids to
basically like talk the older boy out of
it I'm like see violence didn't solve
anything in this movie when push came to
shove it was all about like togetherness
and caring and blah blah blah but it
didn't push out I just loved today
hearing you say the fucking Care Bear
stare didn't do shit today it did I just
thought you just said this at the Care
Bear stare it did not fucking work oh
that would give us one of our favorite
memes which is taste the rainbow
motherfucker yeah I remember you said
that like oh that's pretty finally put
that in I showed to you and you left
really are don't like okay I did I think
it's okay but and now that's like a
really really big line that everyone
remembers that's one of you that I will
totally take credit for it is one of my
personal favorites um so yeah and then
we get the second movie which is not
like oh no what wasn't painful it's not
the worst or anything but it's it's a
rewrite which is already weird
especially the title but then it's like
it's really dull I mean which is so
weird I mean cuz it's like it's Caribee
I know it's hard to say it for something
called Care Bears it just didn't make a
lot of sense to me what it's not even
it's like it's like some camp story and
then these two kids are invited to take
care of little baby Care Bears I'm like
what makes them qualified babysitter's
or veterinarians like you know the and
again it's so weird to say and I think
this may be what the first Care Bears
got which you know is odd to say but I
think even though cuz the story the
first one doesn't make sense either but
it accomplished that emotional
investment that somehow you were still
invested in what's going on in the story
and the characters in the environment
and I mean not a ton but enough to care
haha see other than uh and with and with
the second one it's yeah I think it's
you don't really care about Ava because
there's not really half the time it's
not really a
we going on you know the first one there
was always something for the most part
moving the story along I'm even like
bring the kids up to Caroline
let's show you're on Carolina Bay okay
you can't do that with this one it's
like you know the Care Bears after they
grew up oh we're playing then dark heart
showed up and tried to get them he
didn't so we tried to really get them as
this big you said it wrong no you gotta
say aha um and and the but then they
scared him away but then they have to
chase him for some reason and to this
world that you don't know and don't see
much and it's just it so did not grab
you at all because here's me because it
was so confusing to my six-year-old
brain if there's a magic shop and a
magician it just figures to me that
maybe one of the books is evil it's
magic hmm I didn't get the whole crystal
thing in the in the cloud and the I
don't know I just felt like I don't get
the the only thing that don't know where
Hamer in the mythos of the Care Bears
where where was this coming from the
only but even as a little kid I remember
the only investment I've really and I
did hate the movie as a kid I'll enjoy
anything it's in front of me but the
only vest might really has a kid that
like I remembered coming out of that
what was with dark heart even though he
was a villain and uh and the girl the
camp champ you know if the guy gets even
though she was a brat
it was also but she seemed real she
seemed like a real kid and that was
something I think the Emma seems to be a
common theme in the early care bursaries
don't mess with the dark arts para
Blackmagic whatnot
is something that kids were getting into
the 80s what's been a Dungeons and
Dragons thing mazes and monsters magic
story um but yeah there is something I
think that's in the first Gabrus I'm
sorry had to is that even the kids like
when it starts off they're talking about
how they were just sort of emotionally
distant and it kind of showed in their
performance you kind of got it it's the
same thing with the the girl and this
you kind of got that she does feel
removed and she wants to be something
you know really cool she wants to be a
sign of attention even when she is it's
like she seems happy but she's hiding
out or she's uncomfortable if she sees
you
the Anakin Skywalker and even so the
connection they have like the Care Bears
they're holding me back
well what I like to you know and there's
a scene a Lysaght as a kid when she
saves him on the boat which is really
funny now just the idea that dark heart
would go out like a fucking moron
hitting his head on the canoe but would
you brings him back you know and she was
just sort of like you know and he's like
you saved me why you know I'm clearly
the villain and everything and I
Kimber's ekor exactly responsible along
the lines of I don't know and even
watching that as a kid I was sort of
like I don't know either but yeah just
that kind of felt right that feels like
the right thing again they don't push
out yeah like and that bothers me when I
see that in kids movies where like the
moral of the story is always something
about togetherness and caring and yet at
the end you're just like well but if
somebody I don't like I can chuck that
out the window I mean fuck those guys
like I'm like that's kind of a mixed
message and like these ones they always
just at least the first two stuck to it
honestly I'm having trouble remembering
how the other two ended that's why the
other two was like um and of course it
gave us one of our favorite reads ever
time for a game of disappearing Pez that
kids voice is amazing and he made a man
is a crack-up so many times I would love
to find that actor and just like shake
his hand say thank you for bringing me
so know what accent that is it's like
we're creatures walk yet we were
debating that maybe he was Canadian
that's all right oh yes yeah but it's
like what what is like a Canadian accent
it's kind of hard to say it's like there
definitely is one but it's hard to come
I know it's a doing something very up uh
yeah it's like we can't quite describe
it's just such as weird it sounds a
young Jan love it maybe it looks a
little hmm
III get walk-in I definitely get enough
time for a game of disappearing bears
then that's what I kind of get but it's
such an enjoyable voice has such a
distinct voice um true huh you
underestimate my powers oh uh no and
actually that's a good case to of like
the you know whatever they use this day
or at the end of that movie to but it's
like it's not doing a thing he has to
choose to come back
start carryin stuff so he can say this
does make me wonder though why they have
the stare if it's really ineffective
when push comes to show it works
sometimes than not others I always felt
like it was brainwashing - I felt like
there was no effort of all always not
nice Care Bear stare I'm happy now
well we tried talking when that doesn't
work just London fine Manchurian
Candidate there a sec ok um so yeah sort
of a third in the second third one Care
Bears in Wonderland uh I remember I was
so obsessed with seeing the females
elope desperate to see this moon I was
just like said cuz I love and this is
when they were combining all sorts of
stuff or like looking like Roger Rabbit
and stuff and like why saw Alice in
Wonderland camp it's like those are just
two things I'm loved as a kid I was so
friggin excited there is there is like a
two and a half something like your age
difference between us so I had hit that
point where I'm like I'm fucking done
with this camera yeah no you were like I
do all I ever been is I really hit them
take me to this mom yeah and literally
it's just like like I basically got
dragged to it with dogs I think really I
only remember the ones I saw a toy it
was it a dollar cinema America's we came
in like 10 minutes early ten minutes
late at some strip mall to like
somewhere west of Gaza naman like up up
north from here and it yeah that is my
memory I remember sitting there like
bored out of my mind like this just for
about like an hour and a half and the
only and I like pretty much forgot
everything except for the evil wizard
something having to do with chess maybe
at one point and then at the very end
pickled beets oh that's all I've
remembered from this movie yeah I think
looking back I remember the two little
spider guy whatever they were remind me
of mr. Beasley from the show which I
sure it's the same voice actor um and
like yeah I'm trying to read like the
middle we're like they had to get into
Wonderland and they're looking around
and stuff and there's that we are kind
of song this being played that weird
trippy song like I'm air that looking
really creative I okay this is
Wonderland I kind of get it and you're
doing it okay um you did always have an
Alice in Wonderland fellowship it's
amazing it's still amazing except with
tape
I think it was part easily enough I will
say this the Disney Alice in Wonderland
is one of three tapes we had on beta
when we were like literally toddlers
yeah we watched that Mary Poppins and
Bedknobs and Broomsticks were the first
things we ever saw so I think it got him
like literally like zapped into Doug's
brain yeah we had to watch it also we
saw the words Care Bears it was like
alright and then saw in Wonderland and
just started like sold drooling like
yeah um but yeah even then it's like I
think I saw it twice but even then I
kinda do it's like it was as good as
like the first one I don't know so
something was missing and I couldn't say
what it was
and I'm saw on a Disney Channel cuz I
remember you watching it once it's up
there too yeah I don't think we saw it
twice no IRA Marika's we came in ten
minutes late the second time Wow
it was it was when they were coming into
her room like the creepy stalker says
hey thank you narcotics you made me
forget but um but ya know it was one of
those where it's like it's not again
it's it's probably this colorful just I
retain your little kid apparently
nothing it's nothing of substance
outside of yeah one or two little
creative see very little effort but on
the bright side it's mostly harmless
it's meant for five-year-olds again and
then the Nutcracker one like I was just
like I was finally I think I was at the
stage you were talking about with the
Elsa Wonderland one like I'm starting to
get out I just sort of watched it cuz
nothing else was on and nobody was done
I'm like I think I'm done with this no I
wrote her a funny the funny thing is I
completely forgot about it like I forgot
ever seen it just ran it on TV I they
they did and like when you put it on I
had this acid flashback and I was like
in a fire that I was like whoa like I
literally like the whole background
melted away and that was a she to seeing
it as a kid on TV and I was like whoa
that was amazing like and cuz the one
thing I remembered was that the main
character her name was like mrs. Walker
something and I just always like hey
that's our name dude that's all I
remembered as a kid and yeah that's
pretty much all I remember but that was
the other thing is I remember seeing it
on TV I don't ever remember it being
released in theaters and maybe
was but I don't think it was I hate I
always remembered just it was some hours
special because remember they're
advertising it wasn't even that Saturday
morning cartel longer oh god it felt
long I think that rat was also like
mister mister beastly voice or whatever
um but no I know I remember I was really
getting out of I was really getting out
of that because that's when the two
turtles were coming out to and all I was
thinking myself I really wish the Ninja
Turtles would kick their asses I was
like I bet two Ninja Turtles were here
you'll beaten up the rats and stuff like
that
random crossover ever I said till we
watch it Care Bears versus ninja turd
we're gonna talk about drugs um but yeah
I just remember watching that thinking
like you know man I only want to see his
Ninja Turtles I'm like I think I'm done
with Care Bears
I just want watching into turtles all
time um and a bright light came down
from the sky and the rest was like
welcome back yes
welcome to the next stage of boyhood I
mean it's like that this is stupid too
but it's a whole new level
it's like awesome stupid oh you see a
hood this is awesome Stu fuck the Care
Bears that April owed me oh yeah the
mrs. Walker was kind of hot after I have
no idea what she looks I can't remember
what she looked like
for all I know may she have like
wrinkles all over hers I actually don't
remember cuz it's a very easy movie to
forget surprisingly um that's just the
Digi heparin goes all over her I don't I
I actually totally forgot she exists
until you brought up I'm like oh yeah
she's like telling a story or something
like um she's telling the story of the
Nutcracker that Perry really happened
and that inspired the ballet somehow
it's like really confusing do you want
to do your ballet teacher maybe or
something you know I mean ballet I never
took ballet woo tough I never did my
tears belly really building a dossier
here the Ninja Turtles got me on the
track it interacted to your belly who
also his name mrs. Walker
good say
Freud would have a fun time with this um
I was gonna say time for a game of
disappearing innuendos um so yeah it's
one of those things where I think like
is that like it started off on a high
note but it's like it was surprisingly
giving us more than we probably needed
or deserved or something just something
like that desert and then damaged by the
second one third one there's a little
left and fourth one there was nothing um
so weird to say it is still so strange
to talk about the Care Bear movies like
that but I I know you said well I don't
like I don't hate that movie well I got
the first film I mean really well
honestly as a nostalgia critic thing it
literally literally was nostalgic yeah
cuz I'm like wow this really takes you
back to when I was a kid like Matt oh I
was 17 or no I literally was a small kid
so but it's not just you know the
nostalgia goggles I'm arrows watching
and being like you know like we are
making jokes and stuff yeah looking
bikes we were laughing so hard as so
stupid this is it they were kinda like
you know like I can't with the music in
that track I can't like the pacing they
did there they slowed this idiot down
like a decent job it'll never win any
awards but it was a decent job yeah um
so it's probably about as good as you
can do with Care Bears
now Oh another all CGI they're coming
back how are they uh yeah uh no I know
you know what I saw something they did
like a reboot at some point I just saw
like one of them had like it I think it
was meant to be funny bills like a Care
Bear head and like this robotic body
that was attached to him like that like
the Terminator like that was one of the
villains and I just had to laugh at how
silly that was like I think it was meant
to be silly going recent but you guys
very funny and it you may need a very
violent Care Bear stare for that
thanks come here oh hell no so um yeah
that's uh good god that's like our 20 30
min talking care Faris I hope you
enjoyed it hi I don't think we'll ever
say anything about again I don't know
there's any more to talk about with care
fares I hope it was everything you
expected and more it's not bad